[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm Dave Ramsey your host
thank you for joining us Dr John deloney
number one bestselling author and and
host of the Dr John deloney podcast on
the Ramsey networks is my co-host today
we're happy to talk to you about your
life your money your relationships we're
here to help you do life a little bit
better the phone number is
88255 225 Taylor starts this hour in
Knoxville hi Taylor how are you hey Dave
hey Dr John thank you so much for taking
my call sure what's up so I need some
help navigating money and F family uh my
question is is it wrong for my husband
and I to lie about our accomplishments
and pretend to be broke in order to
financially and emotionally protect
ourselves and I'm happy to give a little
context with that it's just
cowardly yeah
yeah yeah yeah own that yeah
yeah how old are you guys how long y'all
been married tyl so we've been married a
little over a year together for five I
am 32 and my husband is 35 so who's the
twerp that's going to have a hard time
with you
succeeding it's my family uh
specifically my mom okay uh so my my
husband and I have paid off over
$100,000 in student loans over the last
three years and your mom will feel
entitled to some of your money if she
hears you're
winning correct okay correct all right
um almost like I've talked about this
before okay uhhuh uh-huh and so she uses
money to show love but more as a means
of control and yeah anytime one of her
kids starts making money she's got her
hand out wanting some And to clarify she
is financially well off and is not in
need of any help um and she is actually
stolen thousands of dollars from me in
the past when I had my very first job
when I was 16 years years old and when I
her we're pretty much we're pretty much
saying mom's got issues yes why do you
continue to allow your mom to control
you your
30s yeah um I want to honor her as my
mom uh I don't think that's true can I I
don't think that's true I think that
sounds good it's a good church answer
yeah I think you're still trying to
figure out what you did wrong when you
were nine that your mom would steal from
from you and you still think there's a
way there's a thing you haven't done yet
that she'll fin you'll finally do it
you'll finally give her the amount of
money you'll finally do the thing and
she'll go I'm so proud of you and I love
you that's what I think you're chasing
and I think you wrap it up in words like
honor thy father and mother honor thy
father and mother does not mean um honor
their misbehavior
exactly yeah uh in all honesty I would
love to just cut her off completely I
don't think I'm ready to do that I think
that's what makes it hard here's what
you're giving her right now you've given
her money in the past you've given her
your um life in the past now you're
giving her your integrity free rent in
your head don't give her your integrity
anymore tell the truth yeah and when she
says well I want like no we're on a
budget it's a muscle you're going to
have to practice you're you're going to
have to you're going to have to it's
like going to the gym you just never
done squats before you're going have to
start light but you're going to have to
learn how to do squats the first time
you do it your heart rate's going to go
in your stomach it's going to go into
your throat the 80th time you do it
you're just going to be smiling looking
at a poor pitiful lady who hasn't been
able to control her own
emotions yeah cuz that's actually what
she is it's she's kind of pitiful you
will never do a thing that makes her
finally say cuz she doesn't have that
she don't have that to on her kit she
can't do it she doesn't know how right
so you're was an incomplete person who
who's got major major gaps and you you
cannot have any expectation that she's
going to be anything other than that and
you just smile and go no um I mean
pretend like uh she had had a
stroke okay and she was in in she was
incapable of uh behaving you would just
look at her and smile and go gosh that's
a horrible malady you've got but that
still doesn't mean you get to to come
over here and you know throw rocks
through my
window yeah and um we you hear any of
that no you don't want to so bad why you
just kept driving
why H can I okay I'm I'm gonna cut to it
you're scared you're going to haunt your
marriage yeah and at some point your
husband if he hasn't already is going to
ask why her over
me mhm why her over our future that
we're trying to build together yeah
she's taken up a lot of space in your
head
so this may be you guys you may need to
sit down and talk to somebody and work
this through cuz this is a
motherdaughter dysfunction that's pretty
pretty serious and it's just it's just
manifesting itself in the money but it's
there's a lot of other parts of this and
so but the truth is you're not going to
have peace hiding as a 30-year-old
hiding like you're some kind of
misbehaving teenager you know I can't
tell my mom I got good
grades you know I me come on what so cuz
she she does not have the capacity she's
a diminished capacity as if she's had a
stroke we'll just call it that okay and
and it affected her ability to be a good
mom and so you just treat her like that
and it's kind of sad and it's kind of
pitiful and but it doesn't mean I can't
tell her the truth mom you know if it
comes up but you don't need to go in
there and go
da look what we did cuz that's not going
to do it either but you just if it comes
up you just go well you know hey we yeah
we paid off some money but I don't tell
I don't sit down with uh anybody and go
look at what I did yeah how does that
even come up in your house yeah really
well uh when whenever me and my husband
go Which is less and less frequently now
um if I need to go to the restroom or
leave the room they will Corner my
husband and straight up say how much
money did you make this year what are
you making now hold on but but all you
say is I had a good year I don't I'm not
going to give you those numbers and you
smile real big yeah I don't I'm going to
tell you that it's not your business
yeah or when you come out of the
bathroom go hey Mom Dad we don't talk
about our Private Financial uh matters
anymore we just don't we don't put those
numbers out into the world those are
private those are ours and if they can't
honor that boundary then they're asking
you we don't want you
here yeah right that that could be the
exit that I'm looking for no it could be
but that would be them running you off
not you yelling I'm leaving until you
learn to be behave that's not what we're
telling you okay yeah I don't want I
don't want I don't want I don't want I
don't want to talk about my sex life
with you I don't want to talk about my
like the dollar amount we made last year
I don't want to talk about any number of
things that's for us it's not for you as
I started having grandbabies I have had
way more information from my children
about the arrival of children and how
they got here than I wanted to know I'm
just telling you so I just assume we
went her Direction and just said you
know y y'all just keep that to yourself
I really don't want to know some of this
I just want to see the baby when it
comes thank you very much I'm I don't
need to know about the practice thank
you very much it's all good but oh my
gosh it's the same stuff you're exactly
right you're exactly right I'm not going
to tell you about that stuff no no papa
Dave don't want to know Noe Papa Dave
don't want to know I'm just saying want
to meet the baby that's I just show just
tell me what the name is and tell me
what the sex is when it's appropriate to
tell me and then tell me when I can tell
people that and then I will and don't
tell me unless you want me to tell
somebody unless you tell me not to tell
them I need America to know I had a
great joke that I didn't just use you
didn't use
[Applause]
[Music]
it hey guys Ramsey solution started
small and grew fast because of that
rapid growth there were times when our
systems slowed us down that's why we
switched to net site it works for us and
it'll help your business too whether
you're starting on a card table like I
did or you're well on on your way to
becoming a multi-million doll Company
netw Suite can scale with you and help
you communicate and plan better because
you know your day-to-day up and down and
sideways but accounting analytics and
supply chain are on another level so
maybe you're just not techsavvy that can
be okay net Suite will help at your
speed and whatever your situation more
than
37,000 companies use netsuite to know
their numbers and their business better
so check out netw Suite today and find
out how they can help you become the
business you want to be 5 or 30 years
from now and right now you can download
netsuite's free kpi checklist designed
to give you consistently excellent
performance at netsuite.com Ramsey
that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Dr John delone ramsy personality is my
co-host today open phones at
5225 today's question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services when something in your
home breaks remember the neighborly Done
Right promise which is it's not done
until it's done right download the
neighborly app today and schedule your
appointment and you know you're going to
get great service from a great company
these are good people from neighborly
network of local Home
Services all right today's question
comes from flustered in Florida sounds
like a Dear Abby what would your name be
Dave handsome in Nashville devilish
devilish Dave yeah I don't know today's
question comes from fluster in Florida
my wife and I have been married for 9
months and for the last 3 months we've
been working the baby steps we each came
into the marriage with debt our total
combined debt was close to 50 50,000
bucks but I recently cashed in a whole
life policy that was worth 22,000 we've
used it to pay off all our credit cards
and a small student loan that I had had
no problem using this money this way
even though most of the credit card debt
was hers the way I feel is we're now one
and so is our debt however she feels
very guilty about taking this money it
makes her feel indebted to me I hate to
make her feel like she needs to pay me
back since I don't feel like this at all
do you have any advice for this
situation what do you think man uh well
I mean yeah it's it's a discussion of a
view of marriage you know you're not in
debt to your spouse ever you're all into
your you know for richer for poor in
sickness and in health I mean if you get
the flu and she makes your chicken soup
do you have to pay for it in sickness
and in
health you know if she if you're laying
in the bed you know sweating through a
fever cuz you got the flu and uh she's
working and she's taking care of you and
you know so forth do do you have to
write a check for that right you know no
we took we took on each other's burdens
we're our goal once we walk down that
aisle is to serve each other the rest of
our lives to do everything we can to
make the other one's person person and
life better and that includes we took on
each other's debt we took on each
other's income we took on each other's
assets and we took on each other's crazy
parents yeah I I I don't think flustered
in Florida I don't think you can make
your wife feel anything I don't think
you have that kind of power agreed um
and my guess is she probably grew up in
a home where anytime somebody had to do
something for her whether it was buy her
a new pair of shoes or some jeans or get
her to school on time she was was made
to feel like she was a burden to them
and so now she's married somebody who
loves her and is all in and she doesn't
have the for lack of better terms she
doesn't have the script for that she
doesn't have the wiring for that and so
she's going to have to choose on her own
to feel that
discomfort and realize you're not
holding this over her head this isn't an
Roi in fact I Dave I told talked to
somebody recently who's had a
relationship struggle and he said the
person that he was with was listing off
all these things that they do versus and
I said once you get into list once you
get into Roi comparison your your
relationship's in trouble um sometimes
that's an important conversation to have
because it's way out of whack but man
once you start keeping tabs um that can
be the death of a relationship and she
married someone that doesn't do that and
so she's going to have to learn how to
not feel guilty every time she needs
some some support some love and some
care well this is just a it's a
philosophical view of a proper marriage
relationship and the philosophical
theological view is I no longer own
anything we we do own everything and um
that's training that you can decide to
do that we I tell couples all the time
when you get married your pronouns
change it's not mine and yours it's ours
it's we're French we we you know and so
everything's a we it's a pronoun is a
plural now uh and I'm not talking about
pronouns out in the crazy world that's
not what I'm talking about I'm talking
about out of the abundance of your heart
the mouth speaks and go we had some debt
we paid off the debt which is how
flustered feels but his wife didn't feel
that way right and so uh I think we just
talk about it out loud and go look the
right way for us to view this both of us
is that everything that's mine is yours
and everything that's yours is mine
there's not any yours in mind it's ours
and uh if we can get there and start
using our intellect as an act of our
will to practice that and practice
thinking about it that way um
then uh uh you know it changes
everything I'll give you an extreme
example out there for those of you
listening I mean Sharon my wife has not
earned an $1 of income other than
Consignment sale
clothing since Denise was born and
Denise is 38 mhm but we have had a
really good income during those 38 years
right you know or 36 or whatever she is
but I mean you know but we have an
income the Ramsay have an income uh I
technically earned all of it technically
uh except for the part where I get to go
to work all the time cuz she's doing all
this other work that's right but um you
know so it it you can't really bifurcate
all that and it work out any other way
so we have an income and you know and
Sharon Sharon will use that it took a
while but you know she was like Hey you
know you're making pretty good money no
we are making pretty good money we are
we make enough for us to buy that car
that you're going to drive right you
know and you really got to kind of
practice it yeah especially when there's
a single income family yeah or when one
of you brought more assets to the table
in his case they used his whole life
policy to pay off her credit cards but
it's not his and her anymore once you
get married it's ours here's another
side I made this mistake um I bought a
car with cash I don't know 5 years
ago and we didn't take a note out on it
I just bought the car I went down to the
courthouse but I put it in just my name
oh and it never occurred to me and it my
wife
said that makes me feel like you
wouldn't did a thing on your own it
never even it never even no no no this
is ours all this is ours right and so
even even the going back to the
courthouse and changing the name this is
John both of our names are on the title
um which cost a little money it's yeah
important it's an important thing very
important yeah very important well done
so it's something flustered you've been
married a whole 9 months um and so uh
it's something you it's a muscle you
guys can grow into and learn it's very
possible you're going to be just fine
but it gives us a chance to get up on a
soap box and tell everybody how to do it
Cory's in Northfolk Virginia hi Corey
how are
you hey I'm doing good how are you guys
better than we deserve what's
up good uh well me and my wife we're
looking to move from Virginia to North
Carolina uh we have a toddler that is
three years old so we're looking to get
uh to a lower crime city um and
somewhere with better schools so we
currently don't have any debt other than
our mortgage uh we owe about 240 on that
we can sell our home for around 450 here
uh we would be looking to purchase there
for 5 to
600,000 um we'd be looking to roll
probably
175,000 um from our current home in we
also have 125,000 total in savings so
just trying to get an idea of is this a
smart move for us to go ahead and make
um taking you know our emotions out of
the situation and how much would you put
down if it is a good situation I put
down everything I had except for 3 to
six months of expenses and I would put
the payment or put the mortgage that you
take out on a uh 15-year as long as the
payment's no more than a fourth of your
take-home pay then you can afford
this okay and I think you can I think it
I think it fits in your numbers I think
you're just fine
um you are moving to a less expensive
real estate market and still moving up
in house by the way and blaming a little
baby
yeah I would much rather hey I I Dave's
on to something really important I think
for the sake of your relationship with
your kid I think it's important for you
and your wife to say hey we want to move
for a better because we have some goals
for our life but during that stress of
moving that stress of get new driver's
license it can be real easy to look at
that kid and slowly start to resent that
kid we're doing this for you no you're
not you're doing it for y'all and the
kid yeah one new schools too of course
but also it's for y'all yep yep yep yep
yep yep yep that's how that works yeah
just I mean it's it all of it's fine but
you did move up inh house in a cheaper
real estate market um point being you
didn't have to to to accomplish the
school goal only but that's okay you can
afford it I think Cory so I'd probably
go right ahead I just watch my I always
try to think about how I what what I use
to reason my way through that and was
that was that reason process factual and
that's why I'm challenging you just to
help you with that in the future this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
Dr John delone Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Lee and Nicole are on the
debt-free stage in the lobby of ramsy
solutions hey guys how are you hey great
how are you better than we deserve where
do you'all live we live in Greenville
South Carolina oh love it what a great
town beauti welcome to Nashville how
much debt have you paid we paid all
$462,000 W yeah how long did this Take 5
53 months 53 months and your range of
income during that time we started out
at about 180 and then up to 305 wow what
do youall do for a living we're
veterians oh very good both of you both
you on the practice no oh but both of
you making 100 and a half about 8 C or
thereabouts good for y'all student loans
it was yeah those vet loans will get you
man
so bad I took a call last week from a
guy whose wife was wanting to go be a
veterinarian he was trying to he was an
accountant he was trying to figure out
if it was worth it I was with you yeah
yeah I said it was worth it it's worth
it but you got to really think it
through 400 so you've been out of school
5 years I'm guessing uh years almost
years oh okay so what happened after you
know at this it looks like about 5 years
ago this thing blew up what what's the
story so it started in 2015 that's when
we graduated vet school and each of us
Ed probably 170,000 or so uh we were put
on an income based repayment plan as you
do and you know at 6 and a half%
interest 170,000 we weren't even
covering the interest not even and so
between between 2015 and 2019 our loans
went from 170,000 to well over 200,000
in in each double and so it was early
2019 um they didn't do a lot of math in
vet school but even you knew that was
backward right
yeah we we we had no plan to to try to
tackle this we had absolutely no idea
stressful for sure and Thomas Griner um
he's a vet he was our classmate he and I
were working together and early 2019 he
invited us to his church to attend FPU
oh wow and Nicole she was really excited
about it um I was very hesitant I was
like you know we make what we make
what's this Dave guy going to tell us
that we don't already know about money
yeah boy was I wrong
um so early 2019 we went through FPU um
we actually missed week nine the last
one because our son was born oh wow and
uh him coming into the world it just
kind of changed everything we got the
icing on the cake we got to get rid of
this de you know and we don't want him
to have to go through what we did go
through what we did we want to be able
to pay for his college one day so he was
born uh in in early 2019 we had like
$1,000 worth of cell phone debt uh
29,000 between two vehicles and the
remaining 432,000 was our student loans
and so it was it was like late
2019 we started in on my half of the
student loans and uh we still we still
didn't even really know if we could do
it it seemed like such a huge mountain
yeah and then such a timeline early
early 2020 Co thanks Co it helps us so
much so you know we we got the the PA on
the interest and that's when we just
really we were able to through
everything and yall were essential so
you kept working like crazy people
worked more than yeah yeah and you
weren't part of the 99.9% of Americans
who just sat y'all y'all looked at this
as an opportunity it saved us probably
80 $90,000 of interest you know what I
bet it did yeah yeah over five this
period of time that's right cuz you hit
it exactly
right that's amazing we started the
loans just before Co
wow and then early this summer we
actually decided to move to Greenville
we we had been living in Georgia the
entire time um so we sold our house took
some of the equity from it and paid off
the rest of her her loans right before
the payment started back oh perfect so
per perfect timing yeah and then took
new new vet jobs there GRE EXA are
youall working in the same practice we
actually are yeah okay yeah large animal
small animal what small small small
animal and now y'all are 300 plus with
no debt that's right we got get a house
again so that's where we're we're headed
we're in 3B now yeah way to go you guys
that's a different house when you don't
ow $400,000 right right it's going to be
better well you don't need a bedroom for
Sally May that's pretty cool yeah way to
go y'all thank you you got to feel like
I can do anything like you got a super
power it's a weight for sure yep wow all
right hey can I can I ask you a hard
question sure I want you to speak on
behalf of everybody in this industry
okay um and I say this industry that's
not true in with this mindset millions
of people go through
FPU and they know I don't know what I'm
doing yeah there's a whole bunch of
people that make a lot of money that
think ain't nobody going to tell me MH
and they're real smart and they got a
lot of fancy letters after their name
and some huge frame diplomas on their
walls and huge student loan de to go
huge student loan debt and they can't
breathe and they're arrogant at the same
time What finally got through to you
because what you said I hear that all
the time from my medical doctor buddies
my my nurse practitioner buddies what's
this ramsy guy like what what's that oh
okay just just live un less than you
okay man like that's a that's a hard
thing to get through that ego yeah yeah
no it was um you know just going through
the class it all made sense and and when
I when I actually sat down and figured
up the numbers and did the calculations
it's like yeah this would work like all
we've got to do is do it we have to set
our mind to it and just do it just plow
through and go so once I actually ran
the numbers that's what flipped the
mindset it's so daunting looking at the
big picture like that and then if you
kind of scale it back and do one step at
a time like like the baby step show it's
it's much more manageable how do you eat
an elephant a bite at a time exactly it
that's it way to go y'all thank you so
proud of you who was who was cheering
you on telling you you could do it um so
Thomas of course got us started and then
uh our good friends Marcy and Eric
they're watching hey and then my parents
as well all right very good anybody roll
their eyes and say you're
crazy yeah it came up uh quite a bit at
work and we we just mention you know
what we were doing and some people were
like you know yeah that's cool some
people looked at us like we had six
heads like what you're you're throwing
$10,000 a month out the window you know
when you could be buying a bass
boat I mean yeah well and for going that
many years of retirement savings it's
just yeah yeah yeah yeah 53 months I
mean you've been scratching for a while
mhm this is real and you have the junus
car pulling into the uh to the parking
lot well not really cuz that was part of
our debt right oh there you go yeah so a
stupid move is like 6 months before I
graduated V I would have bought a brand
new F-150 of well that's required to
have it's
required I've still got that truck it's
10 years old now but it's paid for yeah
well treat it right and you can give it
to your child when turn 16 right that's
right great job Lee and Nicole way to go
y'all we've got the live and give box
for you it has in it the baby steps
millionaires book you'll be there in a
minute if you're not already and uh of
course The Total Money Makeover book as
well and Financial Peace University
which did it for you guys and uh you
guys can um of course give that to
somebody or go back through again
whatever you need to do all of this is
for you to enjoy or to give away the Liv
and give box so congratul ation very
proud of y'all Heroes you kicked it man
that's a long run right there it's a big
deal all right Lee and Nicole a couple
of veterinarians in Greenville South
Carolina these days making four or paid
off 462,000 53 months making 180 up to
305 count it down let's hear a debt free
Scream 3 2 one we're de
free yeah all right all right
that's how it's done right
there it is amazing that uh for a math
nerd like me that when you crunch
numbers and can see that you can do it
how math becomes hope yeah oh yeah yeah
nobody thinks of math being hope right
but when you go wait a minute I can do
that the first time I ever saw a $100 a
month invested from age 25 to age 65 at
you know in a decent grow stock mutual
fund fun becomes $1,176 th000 the power
of compound interest I thought I could
do $100 and I'm only 22 that's the first
time I saw it and I thought I'm going to
be a millionaire this is really going to
be me Bing math gave me hope it's
imagine it's amazing to me how many very
very smart people don't sit down and do
that very thing cuz like him he just ran
the numbers and then he thought he's a
smart guy he's like oh I can do I got a
path now I can do it I can see it this
is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was was figuring out how
to take care of our health expenses but
we have found a solution that works for
us in an incredible way she loves that
with chm she can help other families who
need it and receive help back when her
own family has an eligible medical event
chm has been a godsend for Jenna that's
her chm story and it could be yours
learn more and join at CH ministries.org
budget
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Alex is in an Arbor
Michigan hey Alex how are you how's it
going guys how are you better than we
deserve sir what's up hey so I am 20
years old a little backstory about me um
I am actually married um I know it's
it's quite a young age um with my
beautiful high school sweetheart of five
years um my father and my grandfather
unfortunately passed away just a couple
months ago W um they they mainly helped
me when it came to finances even though
they were still heavy plastic swipers
um my mom kept my dad's debit card away
quite frequently because of that reason
um my wife and I are kind of just at a
standstill right now um we the way we're
saving money I just feel like isn't
right um we we make about uh about 76
78,000 a year we both do patient
transport at the university hospital um
and uh we don't have much saved up um
and we're just kind of we've got about
$22,000 or $2,200 in debt 22,000
including our cars um we just bought our
first home with a condo um and we're
just kind of seeing what would be the
best way and where we should start
paying our debt off okay all
right it it um sounds like you've got
the opportunity at a young age to really
start uh a whole
plan and Implement every detail of that
plan to get you to where you want to go
and uh right now all you're doing just
trying to make sure we keep the lights
on keep food on the table and nobody
picks up anything Repose it right right
right yeah instead of a plan instead of
a plan you're kind of in survival right
did your did your granddad or dad leave
you any money um no they did not um they
this is all of our all of our money when
it comes to um with the money that we
use for like down payments on our condo
and for you know down payments on our
vehicles and stuff has done 100% self-
earned we haven't received any money we
haven't loaned any money from family or
anything so I want you I want you to
internalize really deeply in your heart
what Dave just said you and your wife at
a really young
age are deciding to change everything
about how y'all do marriage how you do
money and what your kid when he reaches
to be 20 when your daughter reaches the
age of 20 what their life will look like
because of the decisions y'all make
today yeah that's a big deal it's a huge
deal what you're doing I'm proud of you
yeah way to go very very good question
the way your where your mind is the way
you framed the question is you're in a
really good place so what we do is we we
have a class called Financial Peace
University that's nine weeks long and uh
about 10 million people have been
through the class now uh over the last
you know 30 years and so uh and it's of
course the class has evolved and has
gotten better over time and uh but but
in its current form if you go through
that it's everything you should have
been taught about money
uh before we let you out of school you
know but nobody teaches it hardly so
we're going to give that to you guys as
a belated wedding gift and I want you to
go through the class with your wife both
of you attend both of you go to the nine
lessons both of you buy off on here's
what we're going to do you join hands
you get a very clear high definition
picture of where the F what the future
looks like and what the price has to be
paid to get to that future and when you
do that you'll go do it and you're going
to be in a position to you know again
like John said be you'll be very wealthy
uh you haven't made any huge mistakes
you haven't been thrashing around and I
think that's the gift your granddad and
your dad gave you they didn't give you
any real
insight in where money comes from and
how to how to think big about it because
they didn't have any uh we know that
because they didn't leave you any but
the uh uh but they did kind of keep you
tempered to where you haven't gone crazy
like a lot of the people in the public
have gone so you've not got to weigh
huge piles of debt you know you've got
not gone you know some silly numbers in
the numbers you gave me there there's
some trouble there there's some problems
there but there's nothing nothing bad
nothing super bad so if you'll address
the stuff that's there that we teach you
and go do this you're going to be in a
really really good position hang on
Austin I'll pick up and we'll get you
signed up and get you guys to go through
that at 20 years old God Almighty I wish
I'd gone through that at 20 oh dude
don't even get me started be awesome
Natalie is in Logan Utah hey Natalie
welcome to the Ramsey Show oh my gosh
how you guys this is so exciting to talk
to you my heart is racing which seems to
land me in my living room but I'm so
excited to talk to you guys today well
we're excited to talk to you how can we
help okay so I am a mom I have two
little boys I've got a three-year-old
and a five-month-old and so ever since
our three-year-old was born we've put a
small amount of money to the side for
his future and so what I'm wondering is
I recently found out about 529 plans so
I'm trying to figure out we've already
have some money saved up and so it's
like what's the best way to invest that
for our children should we invest it in
stocks should we put it in CDs or I
guess what do you think about 520
accounts that's really what I'm what I'm
wondering here well 529 is used for
Education it grows taxfree which is
wonderful and we always recommend you
put that in good mutual funds that you
control uh 529 in other words what we're
suggesting is mutual funds and the way
it's treated for taxes is dictated by
529 and just like Ira is not a real
investment Ira is how an investment is
treated for taxes and so um that that's
what you're looking for here so if
you're saving for a kid's College 529 is
the way to go and uh you can learn about
them they're really easy to learn about
just go to you know go to Ramsey
solutions.com click on smartvestor Pro
you can sit down with some of the folks
that we endorse around the country for
helping people with the heart of a
teacher with their Investments and they
can help you get that started how much
have you been putting aside for these
kids so both of my boys get $40 a month
so it's $80 a month that we put away for
them okay all right not bad at all good
and so yeah they can sit down with you
and help you put that together and um
you know that that's going to turn into
some money I mean you're it's going to
end up with some money there the uh the
an Esa is the 529 cousin uh the
educational savings account same thing
by mutual fund and qualified as an Esa
uh the maximum on it is $2,000 per year
which would be $1
16667 cents per child per month and if
you did that from 0 to8 you'd have about
$125
$125,000 give or take in there in that
529 uh you would have only put in uh
about let's see 2,000 8 you would put in
about $36,000 so you got about
$90,000
growth that's
taxfree and so that that from a for
fully funding a baby at $2,000 a year6 6
67 a month that set you up and that
today would send you to a an instate
school for your undergrad that would
take care of it what is what's the max
on a 529 it depends on the state 10,000
a year usually you can put more in it
than you should or sometimes you can
load it up like three or four years put
put 10,000 in then quit said it and
forget it it'll grow it'll grow up to be
enough then and you don't you don't have
to keep adding to it every month the
whole 18 years and I've heard recently
that there was adjustment made the last
couple of years that if you're you end
up putting enough money in the 529 your
kid goes to college that they can roll
that into an IRA at some point you can
move it to a Roth IRA but the
limitations on it are pretty severe so I
really wouldn't do I mean think that way
yeah I I would more likely move it to
another family member to go to school
okay uh more than likely it's going to
be a better use of the money but because
the the formula they're using to what
you can move and how long you have to
wait to move it and all that you know
they it was a good idea and then they
mucked it up with too many rules but the
uh um but either way it's still a great
place to save money for a kid for
college uh if you're if they're not
going to go to college it's not a great
place because it has to be used for
education for someone or that $90,000 in
growth will be
penalized and so you're not going to the
fact that it grew tax-free all that
wonderful idea is gone if you don't use
it for that so you got to make sure that
that's what we roll up for but here's
the thing I have never met someone oh by
the way if you if the kid gets a
scholarship you can take that much out
of the 529 and pay no taxes on it at all
so if your kid gets a $2,000 scholarship
you can take 2,000 out of the 529 put it
in your pocket uh that's always been the
argument what if my kid gets a soccer
scholarship or is a genius you can you
know if you get a scholarship you can
take it out uh but here's the thing I
I've been doing this 30 years I have yet
to run into a single person call me up
said Dave you told me to save up for my
kids college and I hate it I hate you I
screwed up everything I hate you this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Dr John deloney number one
bestselling author is my co-host today
Ramsey personality and host of the Dr
John deloney show on your past change
your future was his first one you can
check that out or how to build a
non-anxious life second number one
bestseller just came out last fall you
check it out as well Jonathan is with us
in Fort Meyers Florida hey Jonathan
what's up in your
world Hi how are you doing today Dave
better than I deserve what's up um so I
had a situation happened a couple years
ago uh during Co my mother passed away
um she was actually uh killed by her um
her new husband oh my gosh oh
man yeah they were both in their late
70s um and they um they left me with
quite a bit of
money wow so uh I had never uh I never
made more than about 85 Grand a year and
then was left with a couple million
dollars and I I hope I've been doing the
right steps um with what I've done with
it I just wanted to get mostly some
reassurance that I've been doing the
right things or what you would recommend
uh moving forward with this oh my gosh
how have you navigated the last few
years with the loss of your
mom um you know uh the first year wasn't
too well um you know kind
of you know kind of went backwards
probably a little bit and then trying to
I got a couple kids and I tried to get
myself together and be better for my
kids and I think I've been been doing
pretty well the last two years how old
are you Jonathan uh 36 okay and I assume
he the um the husband's been put in
jail uh no he killed himself afterwards
oh my
gosh yeah wow in our in our house that
we grew up in oh I'm so sorry jeez man
well that just makes it I mean managing
$2 million that you don't know how to
manage is freaky enough and then you put
this l on it it just gets super freaky
right yeah yeah it's a little more than
that um we were left about two 2 million
2 and a half million from our parents um
and then he left us another 1.1 million
oh
wow uh which we weren't expecting we
didn't know that we were written into
his will wow does that money feel weird
or are you happy to spend it
uh uh I I I've spent I haven't really I
wouldn't say I've spent it I've used
most of it to to live off of the last
couple years from the from the the new
husband MH um uh he left us two IRAs a
traditional IRA and a Roth
IRA so I've been
pulling yeah let me get past all the uh
um and just answer your question so how
much money do you have
today um today let me just flip over
here I've got total between properties
and everything
yes I would say about um three and a
half million four million all right and
you're still working making
80 no I I haven't been working since the
day she died oh wow okay what did you do
for a
living I worked in restaurants mostly um
bartender somay and
server okay and and the reason I didn't
go back to work was a lot of that the
reason why I made good money was because
that was that was always
forward about my my life and talking to
people about things in my life and I
just felt like I couldn't do that
anymore well you can't go into this
story part of the story anyway wow okay
are you are you married still or
single no I've never been married I'm
single you said you had kids okay yeah
two children uh one that I have full
custody of one that I split custody okay
an important part of your recovery
moving forward is you're going to have
to get uh you're going to have to get a
job yeah you're going to have to get a
purpose a thing to do a thing to go to a
thing that you are a part of that the
world's going to be better because you
were a part of it you got that yeah I
feel that as well okay yeah it's time
it's time to go back to work Jonathan
doing something yeah I'm actually start
I'm actually starting a business this
year a TBO
business oh a what tour booat a t a tour
a tiki boat tour boat oh okay all right
you're buying the boat and going to yeah
do tours and and do trips on the boat
when uh the boat's going to be delivered
in um April or May of this year and we
should be operating by June okay what
did you spend on that
boat uh 220,000 total okay okay all
right now you're going to be leaning in
learning how to run a business learning
how to handle and operate the boat
you're going to be leaning in on all of
this I really want you to I want you to
go make a living for your sake because
at 36 doing nothing is not a plan okay
for to emotionally and spiritually
John's right about that now so let's
pretend that you're making a living you
don't need this money then right so now
we just need to invest this money
well yes okay Jonathan I buy two things
for Investments um the first thing I
tell people and I was with a bunch of
wealthy people this weekend do not put
money in something you don't understand
don't do it because I do it don't do it
because somebody else says to do it or
you read an article once that's a that's
a nightmare way to lose money put money
in something you understand now that may
mean you need to go to school a little
bit by sitting with an investment
adviser and letting them teach you uh
but I buy real estate that I pay cash
for because I like the real estate
business I've done that already okay and
I buy mutual funds and that's all I
buy okay I've got about um total about
1.8 million in real estate okay and it's
making money
right uh we I have one house that's GNA
be worth about 1.2 million and I'm
planning on renting
that gonna be when why is it not worth
that
now that it's it's about to be finished
being built in I think in March or April
of this year it'll be done okay all
right so you're gonna have and then I
have a I have another rental house and
then I have the house I live in okay
that's fine great now manage those to
where they make a good return on the
amount of money you have tied up in them
and then sit down with a good someone
like a smart Vestor Pro you can find
them at ramsy solutions.com and they'll
help you sit down and start to
understand some mutual funds and invest
it but I mean if you make 10% on $3
million average across that those
Investments then you'd have 300,000 a
year coming in uh if you don't touch it
in 7 years that 3 million at 10% would
be worth about 4 millon would be worth
about 6 million in seven more years it'
be worth about 12 in seven more years it
be worth 24 that's 21 years from today
you're 36 that puts you at
57 with $24
million I like that okay that's you
working providing your own living not
touching these Investments and letting
them just grow at an average growth rate
of 10% a year and that's invested in
mutual funds and real estate now now
it's a little more complicated than that
but basically that's how the math will
roll out the trick here to the thing is
put money in stuff that's steady and is
predictable not super conservative but
not we're not taking any big risks here
we're not trying to reinvent the crypto
world or some bull CRA don't buy t boat
for a quar million dollars and then 6
months go and be like well I'm going to
do this and I'm going to buy a snow cone
stand and then you're going to small
business yourself broke yeah stay stay
on track with that and so you're you're
now in the tiki boo business for the
next decade buddy and you're going to
make a go of it you know get John's
right you don't get to
[Music]
change hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial peace and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumpsum payoff option you could qualify
for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host an is with us in New Orleans hi
Ann how are you hello I'm fine thank you
so much for taking my call our honor how
can we
help okay my question is my husband and
I my ex-husband and I were a co-signer
on my son's condo back in
2004 and since that time he is UN my son
is unable to pay his mortgage because
he's unemployed he lost his job and
2004 no no no we he purchased the condo
in 2004 okay this past April he lost his
job and since and he's been unable to
pay the mortgage how many times did you
pay it since
2004 oh it's happened before about 10
years ago he ran into trouble paying his
uh mortgage and he was able to do a
forbearance and of course I assist it
financially at that time and you keep
using the word unable is he unable or is
he
unwilling yeah why do you not have a job
my best friends in the world is a
paraplegic he is
unable no no he's physically capable
okay he has not and he has not found a
job since April he says he's looking one
the hottest he can't find a job one the
hottest hiring markets in human history
he's chosen not to
work I guess so okay let's use I just
want to be I just want to call a spade a
spade because it helps us make decisions
right yeah now yeah understand you're
still on the
mortgage yes we my ex-husband and I are
co-signers so we're responsible for
paying the note if he does
not and he's not been paying
it yes so I have been paying it since
April my ex-husband made about three of
the mortgage payments so now I want to
know what would be the best Avenue for
me to convince my son to sell it Let It
Go for foreclosure
and I told them or else you get a job
and you pick up the payment but I don't
want it to go to foreclosure because I
don't want it to affect my credit I have
an my credit rating is
820 every time it's paid late it affects
your
credit yes I
understand so I just don't know if
there's any options for me is he on the
note at all coer is he on the Note he's
my my son is the owner of it yeah he's
on the Note she's the co signer yeah
yeah you can't force him to sell it you
can just talk him into selling it will
he sell it if you tell him
to no he's dragging his feet about that
he really doesn't well he's dragging his
feet because he knows you're GNA pay for
20 years you bail him
out yes I understand that and you've
probably given him some Stern talking
toos over the last 20 years and then yes
I have you still paid it so yeah he's
dragging his feet because you taught him
how to I think you have to sit up say
I'm not paying this rent I Dave I'll
leave it to you I mean it's going to
it's going to ruin your your yeah you're
you're going to get foreclosed on if he
gets foreclosed on that's how this works
so can you afford to buy them
out I
could but I I I just don't know what my
best options are because if I buy if I
if he would sell me the condo then it's
mine right for me to do what I want with
it
exactly and then you can then you just
sell it you sell it and right resell it
and get your money back out and at least
that way you didn't lose
anything um but yeah you can just say
all right let get it appraised I'm going
to buy it from you and then you put it
on the market and sell it that's what's
best for
you that is unbelievably
aggravating and it's not necessarily
what's best for him what's best for him
is to experience some
pain um but but he's not going to in
scenario unless you do that's the
problem with co-signing you get to
experience the pain with him and he's
going to play chicken with you and
you've got a lot more to lose than he
does financially right yes I do yeah
yeah what's the what's the condo
worth maybe about
40,000 worse 45 no I would well in the
he would be he would be lucky if he
could get 60 for it oh my God what do
you owe on it 30 okay and he's got 11
more years okay go go go tell him that
um you know he can no longer screw up
your life with his laziness he needs to
sell you this condo even if you buy it
for whatever H have a real estate agent
give you an appraisal buy it for that
amount put it back on the market and
resell it and he needs to
move okay yeah that protects you I'm for
some reason I thought this was a
$600,000 condo it's a $60,000 yeah just
you can you're you're you may lose a
couple thousand bucks here or there by
moving all this gyration around but you
need to get out of this trap you put
yourself in and the trap is
co-signing you can't get out of the Trap
you're either going to be an enabler or
you're not going to pay and then he's
going to get foreclosed on which means
you're going to have a foreclosure on
you and then they're going to come
around looking for all of you wanting
some money out of y'all cuz the condo
won't bring enough at repo to even cover
the old mortgage on it but it's a piece
of crap condo to start
with I'm the one an I'm sorry will you
forgive yourself for the
divorce finally yes
yes you're still trying to make that
right with him stop it's 20
years yes you're going to lose you're
you're going to lose some money but
you're also going to lose your
relationship with your son it's not
worth it yeah I I I would I would buy it
from him have him move out
and turn around put it right back on the
market and sell it and if you lose a
little bit that way that gets you out of
this trap and then you have a standalone
relationship with your son that's
mother's son that is no longer cosigner
cuz cosigner is putting a strain on
everything it's making you do things
you're you don't feel good about and it
makes you resent your son every time
that phone rings you you feel your chest
tighten up cuz what's he going to ask
like it's it's altered your relationship
what's he going to ask for now yeah and
this time cuz you're aggravated with him
like we are for being lazy not working
since April my God how much does it take
to pay the condo note on 30,000 bucks I
mean you can you can like do Uber one
day a month and pull this off this is
about the laziest human I've run into uh
that's pretty rough I mean really yeah
think about it it's just I mean it's not
like it's a lot of money I don't even
know how the boy's eating oh yeah I do
an yeah an's making sure he's got
groceries yeah so Ann you got to stop it
it's time you put him
put him out and let him figure out how
to do life and just love him from a
distance uh that doesn't include your
checkbook for the rest of his life and
that's the biggest favor you can do him
and yourself and moms and dads out there
never ever cosign it's not an active
love it's not it's it's the ultimate
enabling and it locks you into enabling
because out of self-preservation you
have to cover the stupidity of the other
part
what about this Dave I'm trying to think
of how this situation for her could go
wrong is there a moment when and again I
know I'm speaking in ratios here but
$50,000 against what an has is not a lot
of money can she buy this thing and hand
it over to him and walk and dust your
hands off walk away is that too much
enabling I wouldn't do that no yeah no I
think I think it's I think he's not
going to move is what I think or he's
not going to sell it to his mom yeah oh
well I would just take the pain of being
foreclosed on you would I just stop okay
you're either going to sell it to me or
uh the days of me giving you money
you're done they over and that's what
I'm getting at either you're either
either you're going to sell this to me
or you're going to have to figure it out
okay I'm done okay because that's this
is so bad for him yeah she stunned his
emotional growth I mean he's six years
freaking old yeah you can't I can't get
a job since April to pay condo notes on
30,000 bucks this is lame yeah this is
really a lame boy especi when we talk to
elementary school teachers trapped in a
New York apartment during Co who pay off
six figures because they drive and
scratch and Claw and flip and do
whatever they got to do yeah right yeah
it's tough man could sell enough
clothing out of his closet Simon sale
get plasma your way to that one it's
just it's just not any money so um yeah
honey you got you got to get him free of
you and you got to get free of him in
order to have a decent relationship with
him and in order for him to ever be a
real man and it's going to cost you that
precious 820 that you're really you're
really proud of it's going to cost you
gives a about that let that stupid thing
go yeah oh my gosh now condo's never
been late she paid it on time every time
every time it's never been late it
wouldn't be 8:20 this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com and
save up to 35% off everything sitewide
that's blinds.com to learn
[Music]
more
Dr John delone Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Ryan and Haley are with us
on the debt free stage yep right here in
the lobby of Ramy Solutions how are you
guys great wonderful how are you better
than we deserve where do you live
Lewisburg Kan Kansas about 45 minutes
south of Kansas City so uh yeah you need
to be wearing some Kansas City Gear
today for sure oh yeah of course yeah wi
right baby yeah here we go man here we
go way to go good stuff so how much debt
have you guys paid off uh
48,6 wow love it how long did that take
uh 6 years 6 years mhm and your range of
income during that time well when we
first started it was around 100 our Peak
was 260 and we went down down to 112 now
okay that was with the job change okay
so all right very cool good good good
and uh 459,000 what kind of debt was
this uh a little bit everything of
course um so we have a few cars that we
paid off um of course our student loans
we paid for um credit cards and our
house paid off your house look at at
weird people I love it very good great
job what's this house work uh right at
350 good for you man that's awesome how
old are you to 35 and have a paid for
house and now don't have to work as much
so took a different job and downsized
one job and all that kind of stuff
finally got to do the thing he likes to
do doesn't have to work yeah you know
very very cool excellent job excellent
job well for those of you out there in
America that don't know we have a
program here at Ramsey called smart
dollar and it's from the financial
Wellness side of things what happens is
companies uh buy smart dollar and
provide the uh the financial curriculum
to free to their employees and it's
having a massive impact on employees all
across America U-Haul had a bunch of
their folks come on here a few months
ago and do debt-free screams we've had
you know Costco has taken their folks
through it it's uh and companies of all
sizes not just huge ones like U-Haul and
Costco but I understand that your
company bought smart dollar and that's
what got you got started is that right
that is for the most part I mean uh I
was we were already doing the program
really before but it just added an extra
uh when we started working there because
I started working there about eight
months ago oh okay so you were well on
your way and this just help you the the
new job that you got that you love is
the company that has smart dollar yep
well that's good news Okay so a little
bit worried about it there for a minute
all right and so your company name that
furnishes smart dollars what uh strategy
LLC strategy LLC what do they do uh it's
a marketing company web development and
then it okay what do you do I'm in the
it side okay cool and Haley what did you
used to do I'm a nurse You're you are a
nurse okay okay good very good so what
happened this many months ago they all
just even before strategy LLC was doing
it you you guys were already game on and
then you you 60 months into this or six
years into this you knock it out what
got all this started John's right well
you know we got married back in 2017 and
then you know we started making some
decent money and so when you make decent
money you go out and buy new things oh
of course bought three new vehicles
within like six months um brand new so
you know a lot of appreciation on those
two drivers for two drivers Mak sense
yeah you toys too
so motorcycles you know all that so we
uh bought those and then you know when
we're paying 2,000 a month on just
payments good Lord for three vehicles
good Lord um yeah it kind of is
overwhelming it was a w yeah kind of a
wake up call kind of so then our son we
uh he was born
19 um he's staying home today but uh uh
he was born 19 or 21 sorry 21 and uh we
were like we just want to have a good
life for him and so we just kind of
buckled down before um and just went
after it so okay very fine so you ran
into us earlier yes the process and then
it was just added on to when you went to
work for uh strategy LLC yep okay it was
it was awesome program how did you
convince him to sell the motorcycle we
didn't oh okay they're all paid for you
we had to keep them you just paid them
off okay we paid them off she's smiling
we we got to keep them she's riding we
did she has her own as well so what what
are these bikes you married well Ryan uh
hary they're Harley so yeah got Street
Glide and then she's got a Sportster so
I love it very fun you are so much
cooler than I am Haley it's embarrassing
that's so that's a very low bar but
you're way cooler man
yeah way to go you guys thank you and
you're how old 35 and you have paid for
house
$350,000 how's that feel amazing it's
just different I mean uh it's hard to
imagine it really we we actually made
our last uh payment it was like October
1st I think we did and uh it's still not
settling yet that we had made the goal
to ourselves that we wanted to pay it
off by Christmas and that would be our
Christmas present to ourselves um so we
really crank down and worked extra
shifts and um he was working a couple
extra as side jobs to make the extra
money and we were able to pay it in
October not in December love it yeah
very cool very cool man that's it's it's
a great place you are six years is a
long time to crank on this it how did
you stay with it well we really were
like hyper focused on in the last two
years mainly we really enjoyed like your
podcasts and um the books and everything
that we've been reading over the years
um but the last two years are really
when we've been cranking down and
focusing on it a lot a lot of our
culture will tell us that success is a
dollar amount mhm and we don't often ask
the question like what what do I
actually want to be doing we just get
good at something and then they reward
us with money and we do more of it and
we do it faster and then all a sudden we
making great money and everyone's
telling us look how lucky you should
feel and inside you're dying right oh
yeah talk to the person who feels like
they have golden handcuffs they're stuck
because quote unquote they make all this
money you look like a guy who's free
yall look like a family who's free and
y'all made a choice to basically cut
your income in half right we did but it
looks like it was the right thing for
you yeah you just got to I mean as long
as you you know focus and you work if if
you have a spouse you work with them
together um you have to do it both
together it can't be separate um and
that's the biggest thing we just were we
were helping each other kind of feeding
off each other and I think that's the
best thing or if you don't have any
spouse or anybody you got to find
somebody to keep you accountable
some positive peer pressure with the
guys with your company all doing this at
the same time yeah I mean uh they're
actually it's actually pretty cool CU
they're all know we paid the house off
and they're all like you know now we
want to do this too so yeah you're
inspiring them that's kind of yeah and
it's very good feeling I mean we don't
like to you know we're not those type of
people but it's kind of really inspiring
and stuff even for us to be here so well
there's a difference between bragging
and setting an example correct and you
just set an example well done good for
you guys I'm so proud of you thank you
who was cheering you along who was
telling you to go for it I mean really
everybody yeah our whole family both
sides um my son son he's even though
he's only two he's just been our our
like emotional support guy he's been
hanging in there with us yeah my uh my
dad started me a lot um when he was we
would drive around um he'd be listening
to your podcast and this was long long
time ago and just never really did it
and uh you know my dad passed away in 19
and so we uh that was one thing I wanted
to do is I wanted to finish this I
wanted to do this and kind of you know
for him so yeah yeah absolutely well
he's smiling oh yeah smiling from Heaven
at you right now yeah what a way to
honor your dad man that's cool yep very
awesome all right we've got the live and
give box for you that includes the baby
steps millionaires book you're on your
way to that for sure Total Money
Makeover book Financial Peace University
you'll be able to give that away since
uh strategy l l c is Furnishing smart
dollar to their whole team and tell them
thanks for us we appreciate it that's
pretty incredible this what happens
employers when you uh when you furnish
something like Financial Wellness like
this to your a smart dollar program to
your employees they um they're set up to
win like this this is incredible all
right Ryan and Haley wow Kansas City
459,000 paid off in 6 years making 100
to 260 count it down let's hear a
debt-free screen
ready 3 2 1 we're de
free love
[Applause]
Ito love it way to go you
guys hey you mentioned something Dave
that I don't want us to
lose now that that company put this this
benefit out they're really successful
he's going to be a better employee yep
he's going to be a more peaceful
employee they get to pay him less he's
going to knock it out of the park for
yep smartdollar.com Check It Out
[Music]
Boys
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality
number one bestselling author is my
co-host today Dan is with us in
Greenville South Carolina hi Dan how are
you
hey I'm good hope you guys are doing
well we are sir what's
up so question for you about the um I'm
on a all
commission position and in reading your
book in regards to the hills and
Valley's account that you have set up um
so i' I've got myself budgeted out to
the end of April and then I've got some
about 12,000 extra on top of that do I
throw that extra 12,000 straight at debt
or should I be adding another line item
into my budget no
justb if you're in baby are you in baby
step two correct yeah just list your
debt smallest to largest every excess
dollar you can squeeze out of your
budget above your basic living
expenses um you throw it at that now do
you have any money have do you have down
months below where you never where you
don't even make enough commission to
cover your basics
yes yeah so commercial real estate so
for instance um December commission
check was 67,000 for December but the
first the the probably six months before
that it was zero to $1,000 you know so
it really varies and so I have to budget
myself out for months at a time and My
worry is that I throw some extra money
when I have it at some debt and then
maybe a deal does go through or a deal
gets extended and I there I am with a
paid off car but I should have had money
in my in my account so that's that's
what I'm struggling with there yeah it's
you know what we're trying to do is
reasonably predict the
volatility and how long have you been
doing
this three years commercial real estate
okay I mean you you you probably can get
some comfort from looking at the
patterns if you went back three years
you should see a trend line up in your
income
overall your overall income should be
going up over three years you should be
making more three years in than you did
the first year right correct okay and
you can tell if there's some kind of a
rhythm at all to uh you know about how
often you see checks coming and going
but um yeah you just you know the the
valley account if you're going to have
an extreme volatility like you do where
you literally have zero or have $1,000
or something um then you've got to set
aside money for as many
months um in that Valley account cuz
you're in a valley uh to cover your
basic needs till you get another check
in yeah that's exactly what we're
talking about so
um you know there's not a uh we have to
we have to try to predict the future is
what we're doing right which of course
is an imperfect science but um you know
if you had six mon this is not your
emergency fund this is money to eat with
okay this is us planning to make no
money for four months so we set four
months of Basics aside in a separate
account that's called the valley account
you do that when you have a hill like
December with 20 $67,000 in one month so
the trick is to try to ascertain with
some kind of pattern if you look on your
look back uh you know how often am I
going to have to dip into this account
to
eat and keep the basic keep the basic
lights on and everything above that then
you need to dump but you should reach a
point where you're getting something
every month you should not continue to
get Z to have zeros the rest of your
life I mean you ought to be able to get
your pipeline full to where something is
coming out all the time now it might
take a little while to get there it
might be every other month or something
but um otherwise I'm going to put
something else in your mix you're only
elephant hunting and I'm going to put a
few rabbits in your in your mix as well
I mean let's try to do some lease deals
or something that's a little smaller a
little more quick to close that kind of
thing than just selling the $35 million
apartment complex or whatever if you're
only hunting elephants you may have this
the rest of your life uh but but you
really do have to get some something
built up to where you're not sitting
around
hungry waiting on one of these checks
you're right so I but the magic is to
predict the future that that's tells you
how much you got to set aside for how
many down months you're going to have
and that's very difficult to do in your
world but that that is the concept you
you nailed it when you called in thanks
for joining
us uh nothing quite like um even in
something as sophisticated as commercial
real estate nothing smells bad like a
Salesman that's broke yeah and
I the analogy you gave is good and I
think I could I could put that on
everything uh marriages on work
relationships on jobs so often we sit
around waiting for the perfect situation
it's got to be a home run or I'm not
swinging the bat and you end up striking
out a whole bunch right or you get real
hungry uh and then it makes you not an
effective salesman yep and but that
elephant hunting man finding another way
to get some money that's I was going to
ask him like for those four months are
you making calls all day are you out
surveying properties all day and you
just can't get anything cuz that may not
be your call Man four months you got
nothing man that's tough that's tough
yeah and and one $35 million deal does
not
take four months
of 40 hour 40 hour work weeks that's
right that's not how it works it's all
you're you know when you're on you got
to be on but you're not there 40 hours
they got to talk to their team and their
banker and their people but not for 40
hours a week for four months you need to
have other stuff in your pipeline and
that's the nature of the real estate
business I've been in it my whole life
in one way or another another all right
Deborah is with us in Milwaukee hi
Deborah how are
you hi there um thank you for having me
sure how can we help okay um my
daughter's actually um introduced me to
your name in uh December okay and I've
been listening to you quite a bit so um
real quick my I'm I'm retired I've been
retired for a while and I'm $225,000 in
credit card debt rutro
yep r r was right um I guess as I'm
listening as I've listened to you guys
the different times and it's like and I
see that I turned that Blind Eye to what
was happening and um and so when I just
look at everything I don't know how to
start everything so I've I've signed up
for everything that you have and I I got
the book the other day and um but so how
old are
you I am 68 68 and how much in credit
card debt have you run up 255 25,000 you
have any
money no none I mean well you know one I
um I I only have about 20,000 in my 401k
because I messed well about 30,000
because I messed that up
too what are you living on you have a
retirement income from your old
job no that's that's done I and I I get
3879 that's my income every month
M Social Security yeah that's Social
Security it's Social Security I get uh
something from a job that I worked for
for about 10 years uh back in the 8
how's your
health my health is okay okay my health
is okay and I have a
condo um that I own outright good that
you live in for no I do not I live in um
home with my husband oh what does your
husband make pray
tell um he makes over
$100,000 and I'm gonna tell you I
listened to
your ear he and I have always been
separate yeah not anymore now he's
married to a woman that's got $28,000 in
debt and he's 68 I thought you were a
single 68- year old lady living on
Social Security and I was about to put
you to work until I discovered you have
a husband that has a $100,000 income
and now I'm about to take some of his
money to pay off his wife's debt which
is what he needs to do tell Bubba to
step up and take care of this and by the
way you need to cut up your credit card
sister chop them all up and never do
that again uh but you guys are uh you're
together if he gets sick you're going to
take care of him and right now you're
sick and he's going to take care of you
and y'all have been playing house for a
long long time and now y'all need to
have a conversation about what the back
20 years is going to look like yeah and
that's going to be all working together
whether financially healthwise marriage
wise
housewise y'all got too much money you
got a extra paid for a house over here
you got too much stuff going around to
be this broke and they're scared about
it yeah unable to breathe because of
Social Security the magic listen the
plans are important the books are great
sometimes the magic is in that hard work
or in that really hard conversation and
that's where you are yeah you guys need
to sit down and talk about this and he
needs to help you pay it off silly to
sell a cond to pay off this when he
makes that kind of money this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Ken Coleman number one
bestselling author of the book paycheck
to purpose host of the Ken Coleman show
is my co-host today thank you for
joining us America open phones at
5225 Ken long before there was a Ken
Coleman uh when I first started this uh
broadcast a long long time ago it was
called the money game yes and uh back in
those days 30 years ago we were on in
Nashville only and um a friend of mine
that I I had known uh from church put a
book out helping people like you do in
the career space 48 days to the work you
love name's Dan Miller and uh Dan and
his wife Joanne have been friends with
Sharon's and mine for almost 40 years
now wow and
um uh 48 days became a perennial
bestseller sold millions of copies uh
and helped millions of people in the
same space that you're in with their
career and selecting the right passion
and all of those kind things Dan and I
were in a Bible study with a bunch of
high performing guys we called it the
Eagles group uh when we met every
Wednesday morning uh for 14 years and uh
that group uh disbanded it ran its
course several years ago about a decade
ago or so and Dan moved he and Joan
moved to Florida and he uh uh he called
me in December and told me he had very
aggressive cancer and uh he uh he went
home to be with Jesus last night about 9
9:15 and so lost a dear friend and a guy
that an icon in the space that you're in
for sure yeah and uh um has helped a lot
of people in that career space so we'll
honor him today and yeah um and continue
to cry and pray with his family and uh
so just incredible incredible friend
incredible man uh great dad great
husband too that's what people sometimes
behind the scenes you don't know what
people are and this guy's like the real
dude well you know he I I had the
privilege of having dinner with a couple
guys that uh he has mentored and about
my age and just the way they talked
about him of course I got to know Dan
was on his show and had interview Dan on
my show as well and uh you know when you
think about someone's Legacy it's the
impact that they leave behind that has
nothing to do with the public stuff and
he had a tremendous impact there but
just the way he has impacted people for
decades pouring into guys and a
mastermind group I got to talk to two of
these guys and they just they both uh
teared up just talking about the impact
that he had had on their lives Y what
it's all about absolutely quite a legacy
yeah quite a legacy great man quite a
guy so our uh condolences to our friends
there and just take a second and honor
the work that he had done is absolutely
incredible all right Billy is with us
Billy is in Atlanta Georgia hi Billy how
are you hello Dave hello Ken how are you
guys better than we deserve what's
up well uh my wife and I want to make a
new car purchase for the first time in
over a decade and I just want to make
sure that it's going to be a predes
sizable car purchase and I just want to
make sure that this makes sense from
your perspective we've been follower
years followers of years for quite some
time now and I would just like to get
the Dave blessing if I
can well it's not something that's
required for a car I can tell you that
if you've been following us a long time
you know that we don't buy new cars
unless you have at least a million
dollar net worth are you talking about
new to you or a brand new car it's a
brand new car and the only reason why
I'm calling in is because before I was
about 10 grand underneath the
millionaire status and now as of this
morning I'm
$3,999 over the millionaire status just
cross the finish line all right so sure
you're ready to go on that one all right
and you probably also know we tell folks
regardless of their level of wealth not
to buy things with wheels and Motors all
added together that equals more than
half your annual income so what's your
household income about half a million
dollars wow you're killing it what do
you do for a living
I'm a Solutions architect at a
technology company and my wife's a tech
sales executive at a startup phenomenal
way to go you guys well it sounds like
you're going to be able to afford this
car what is it what kind of car it's a
electric SUV it's arivan and I know
you're a car guy so it goes 0 to 60 and
3 seconds yeah I know the rivan yeah I
was talking to a guy I bought one the
other day I parked beside him at church
and I parked my Raptor beside him we
were talking about it as we're walking
into church it was kind of it was a
great conversation it was a lot of fun
so um so it's a wonderful vehicle for I
mean if you like the electric stuff
everybody I mean they're just it's an
incredible the engineering is very cool
what is that thing about 90 grand 100
Grand uh out the door with tax title
license and everything 98,000 yeah okay
all right and I assume you've got the
cash yes I just crossed 100 Grand on the
high yield savings account so I wanted
pay for everything you know the
insurance for the whole year and
everything as well so unless your wife
is driving a $150,000 vehicle your two
vehicles would be under half your annual
income and you're over a million dollars
and you're paying cash that's the only
thing we tell people to look
at awesome awesome yeah and we're
driving right now like a 10-year-old
Hyundai and we're still going to keep it
until it dies just for like memory sake
yeah yeah yeah I mean it's
uh yeah it's apparently the engineering
on this thing is incredible I've not
driven one of them uh the only thing I
worry about with a brand new
manufacturer on anything yeah is I end
up owning a DeLorean or something right
mm yep you know or studa Baker or
something that goes out of business you
know and and then leaves you you know
they may they make them for three years
and then they're gone I don't I don't
have any reason to think that this
company's going to do that but I'm just
saying in just as a general comment but
can you afford this yes you can afford
it sir and yes you should go buy it if
it's what you want amazing thank you
Dave I really appreciate it very cool
that's fun very fun he walked through it
I don't get to do that very often most
of the time I say don't buy the car well
yeah or sell the car right usually when
they call saying I need your blessing
it's because they feel like they're
ready to do something stupid that's
stupid please save me but this guy had
uh walked right through it I I'm with
you I still wouldn't do it a car taste
yeah I would do it I get a year old one
or something like that cuz it is a new
manufacturer but you know I guess it's
coming with all the warranties and
everything but it's brand new I see him
driving all over the place they're great
they got a dealership about a mile and a
half from my house downtown Franklin so
I see them they look I'm telling you
it's a ba car man it it'll ride it'll go
it's faster than 0 to 60 in 3 seconds
it's it makes a Tesla look yeah what's
the uh is it is it a foreign
manufacturer I guess no they're us it's
a us okay all right didn't even know
yeah it's crazy but ah man it's
expensive too but it's good it's hey
that's what this is why you work you
live like no one else so later you can
live like no one else freaking making a
half million doll a year got a million
dollar net worth young guy but um and
has saved up the cash to do it and
that's what he he's making a big leap up
big jump from a I feel bad for the poor
Hyundai for a hoopie the 10-year-old
Hyundai's gonna feel bad when the new
shiny vehicle shows up but they're going
to keep it I like it yeah so what's the
thing on the Hyundai's all getting
stolen have you seen the Tik Tok thing
no you know Dave I'm not on Tik Tok I'm
not either but I heard it this morning I
heard it this morning in a different
setting that it's hard to have that
there's some kind of a this is true a
guy in the audience is shaking his head
it's hard to get insurance on them
they're getting stolen because the
somebody put out a hack on how to how to
get one started how to break into it and
all these people are using that hack oh
and they're stealing Hyundai okay like
crazy so you Hyundai people be careful
out there wow wow get the low Jack who
knew who knew this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
a
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today hey folks we want you to
join us in Nashville for a brand new
event that we just launched the ticket
sales on it's called The Total Money
Makeover weekend it's going to be May
10th and 11th there's millions of you
out there who have been listening for a
while and are still sitting on the
sidelines no more setting it's time to
do it time to take action in just one
weekend we're going to give you a crash
course on everything we teach you about
money and you're going to hear brand new
content in addition to that from the
Ramsey personalities on budgeting
beating debt investing careers and more
no matter what baby step you're on this
event will light a fire under your butt
and you'll make progress all the Ramsey
personalities including Ken Coleman and
my right will be part of this weekend
The Total Money Makeover weekend it's
going to Be Live question and answers
all throughout the weekend lots of
opportunities for fun and pictures and
everything else it is a total immersion
so come join us May 10 and 11 early bird
tickets went on sale uh just a couple
days ago at $99 and they are for a
limited time we're going to re we're
going to up the prices as we go along so
if you want the best prices you do it
now get your tickets right now at ramsy
solutions.com
events The Event Center only holds 2500
folks so you do need to get your tickets
as soon as possible please for your sake
Cassandra is in Colorado Springs hi
Cassandra how are you hi guys I'm good
how are you guys better than we deserve
what's up so I'm curious about doing um
a HELOC to consolidate our debt to pay
it off
[Music]
quicker so um we have about 55,000 that
we are wanting to pay off but what I was
hoping to do was to do the HELOC um so
pull out the 55,000 and then do about a
$400 payment a week so it would be
either an automatic withdrawal or we do
well automatic is easier so if we do the
automatic withdrawal um and then I'm
hoping it would be paid off in about
three years not at 18,000 a year it
won't
be the interest is 18 no six or 400 a
week is 1,600 a
month that's $199,000 a year times three
is not
55 it might get there you might get
there but it's going to be tough yeah
you'll get there I guess but uh uh okay
so
um all so what kind of debt is
this um we've got about uh just under
10,000 on a credit card and then the
rest are Auto loans no student loans and
this is not including the house so
what's your household
income uh like after taxes take home is
about 7,100 a
month husband has two jobs and then I um
also work on commissions so I get um
bonuses and so whatever we get in those
extra incomes go straight to debt but
I'm wanting it to go faster so the going
going faster will be about you guys uh
sacrificing and cutting deeper it won't
be about interest interest rate's not
your problem when you have only a 2year
or a three-year problem uh your your
problem is just straight cash flow and
you can increase that of course by
increasing income or decreasing outgo
which is sacrifice the the problem with
it with with moving this onto your home
is you've now put your home at risk for
your misbehavior and your misbehavior
was you bought things you couldn't
afford to
buy right and now recognizing that and
changing that behavior yeah maybe 88% of
the people that do debt consolidation
end up going further in debt not less
debt because they don't change the
habits and the behavior I personally
would tell you to never do it I would
list these debts smallest to largest I'd
cut up the credit cards um I would
sacrifice so deeply that people think
you join joined a cult I'd sell so much
stuff the kids think they're next I
would go crazy and get this done in
about 2 years
with your income and live on nothing not
going out to eat not going on vacation
uh not looking for an easy way out
attacking this with an absolute freaking
Vengeance um that's the formula that we
have seen that has the most
success um because here's the thing debt
is not the problem debt is the symptom
and interest rates when you run the
actual math are not what's killing you
here uh especially when you pay those
credit cards off off really really fast
cuz they're going to be the smaller of
these debts the cars are going to be the
larger of the debts and so when you list
these things smallest to largest pay
minimum on everything but the little one
attack the little one with a Vengeance
credit cards are going to be the first
thing out the door they're going to be
gone and so now your interest rates are
not going to be substantially different
from that point forward between that and
the HELOC and you put your home at risk
to buy a
car or in this case to keep a car that
you shouldn't have bought yeah the Kei
that we have seen Cassandra in all these
years when Dave talks about you've heard
him talk about it over and over and over
again gazelle intensity the word there
is urgency and here's what happens when
you take the route of the HELOC you
remove all urgency in fact the way you
laid it out to us was so relaxed and
we'll pay $400 a week and in three years
we'll pay it off and that's where the
that's where things go AR and Dave's
right and the data backs him up so
urgency is we don't rely on the helck we
don't rely on a steady monthly payment
to get out of this we get after it right
now we sell a car if we've got some
Equity we drive a a car that maybe we
wouldn't choose to drive you know we
work two and three extra jobs we
sacrifice like Dave talked about what's
going on there is urgency and when your
your urgency is driving behavior you're
going to see faster results you're and
you see permanent Behavior change that's
correct because you don't ever want to
do that again yeah you don't you don't
see that when you uh just ease into it
that's right the helo's too easy yeah
I'm going to keep eating Donuts but I'm
also going to start having a protein
shake yeah I'm going to I'm going to
walk five miles a day but I'm not giving
up the donuts that's right and six Big
Max at lunch yeah and so yeah that
that's you know that that is the
equivalent of what we're talking about
it's you there is a thing so you you
asked and so we're answering you fairly
and that is I wouldn't do it because
when you lean into this with that
urgency with that level of sacrifice
you'll never go back it causes the
behavior to to permanently be changed
because you never see it the same way
again this is not a math problem it's a
behavior problem and when you address it
through that lens it changes the answer
dramatically here never would I see you
go out to eat and you put a steak on
your credit card and then you put your
credit card on your home you've now
financed a steak on a HELOC o that's a
great way of looking at it I mean that's
just when you think about it it's just
nuts all right Roger is in Tampa Florida
hey Roger welcome to the Ramsey
show how you doing Dave how you doing Dr
John uh great Ken's with me this hour
what's up oh sorry about that good all
good Ken likes to be called doctor but
it's just not called doctor ever so I'm
gonna take
it cool well um all right my question is
you know I I've worked in the wedding
industry doing music for for weddings
for almost 18 years now and uh uh in
2022 I was making about you know8
$880,000
uh a year halfway through 2022 I decided
to go into business for myself um last
year
2023 I did really well and took in about
uh almost
$250,000 to raise my income up um and
the same thing doing the same thing and
the same thing just just starting yeah
good for you
thank you so you know we spent the last
year we paid off our credit cards uh we
don't have any car loans or anything but
we do have two loans that are kind of
hanging over my head and I'm a little
overwhelmed just trying to figure out
how to manage the money we have my wife
has about $12,000 in student debt and I
years ago made a bad decision took out
an SBA loan small business assers some
loan and it's about $100,000 that I took
out so you got $220,000 to pay off and
you made two 50 last year correct dude
you used to make
80 yeah live on your old income and your
Deb free in two
years yes okay so my well the question I
have to you is uh you know because as
the business is really grown pretty
quickly almost almost quick quicker than
I a lot quicker than I expected so I'm
like facing these issues where not
issues but I I need to I'm I'm looking
at Future jobs and realizing that I need
to purchase I need to make no you don't
need to purchase anything else you need
to keep making $250,000 and pay off
$220,000 in debt you don't need to be
buying anything right now you got to
clean up your mess
[Music]
first
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today one of our other fellow
Ramsey personalities is in the middle of
book launch week we're uh tomorrow will
be one week that the book has been out
Breaking Free from broke by George camel
The Ultimate Guide to more money and
less stress it is fun and packed with
research and you will never look at some
of the villain in the marketplace the
same again he exposes everyone that is
ripping you off in Breaking Free from
broke you will love the read it's a lot
of fun to read a lot of people hadn't
read a book in 5 years of reading it
that's a good indicator that's a good
book George camel check it out you can
get it at Ramsey solutions.com or
anywhere great books are sold Lexi is in
St Paul Minnesota hi Lexi welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hi thank you so much for having me
how are you guys today better than we
deserve what's
up hi um I just wanted your advice on um
some career uh
trajectories um I just gave some
background I'm a recent a law student
graduate um I chose my law school
because I got a full ride so I'm out
debt free great good for you and thank
you um and I took a job with my State's
government as a civil litigator where I
currently make $80,000 a year um and I
love this job because I get the
mentorship of a corporate law firm but I
get to do work that is Meaningful to me
and I get to volunteer 15 hours a
week work that you're doing that's
meaningful um I get to help uh protect
people in my state uh from Bad actors
protect who not in criminal uh residents
of my state residents of your state so
who are The Bad actors give us an
example of who you're protecting them
from um so I mean if there's um someone
who it isn't paying Fair wages to their
employees or there's harassment in the
workplace I get to help step been and
make sure that that isn't happening to
my my fellow citizens is that a form of
you working for the attorney
yeah are you working for the Attorney
General yes sir okay all right I'm
trying to make sure we that makes sense
then okay cool yeah and I I love the
work I get a lot of really great
mentorship I get to go into court three
to four days a week which a lot of my
classmates who went into dig La I mean
they're in cubicles I don't right
they're not getting the experienc I am
um and I get to to volunteer right I run
a housing Clinic uh through a legal aid
I I get to volunteer 15 hours a week um
but I chose my law school because I
would come out jtree and I I went into
it after spending three years working
for a legal aid and that's really where
my heart is that's where I want to give
back to um and I'm wondering if I should
suck it up and go into a corporate law
firm where I'd make an additional
hundred 000 a year easily um pay off my
house and you know be able to to really
give myself to Legal Aid without any
Financial burdens or if I should go
straight to Legal Aid work and you know
potentially burn out because it's a
lower lower paid position and option a
hard work option A I'm now this is me
I'm GNA answered is what would I do if I
were in your shoes with everything
you've given me um you love the work
that you do you love the result of that
work and you want to volunteer and legal
aid is close to your heart but the
reality is is that if you go into a
legal aid position you are probably
going to burn out your income is going
to be absolutely capped and I don't know
that you're making more of a difference
working in that type of a situation 40
hours a week 50 hours a week as you
would uh going to work for a great law
firm with no cap essentially or
certainly raise the cap tremendously on
your income ability and then give back
with your time that way the more money
you make and the more money you keep
Lexi always leads to more freedom more
options with what you want to do with
your time you can give back financially
and you can give back with your time in
both positions and I think you've got to
create more income and more freedom for
you to be able to have more impact now
I'm not going to say that you wouldn't
make great impact it wouldn't be
fulfilled but I'm telling you what I
would do I choose both income and impact
Dave is what I would choose because you
still volunteer Mak money there the good
news is there's almost an infinite
number of answers to your question yeah
there's a lot of different ways you can
use the law uh to accomplish your goal
and um I I don't think it's uh
necessarily um you know all all in on
legal aid versus all in on big law and I
lose my soul but I make a lot of money
so I can come back find my soul again
you know that kind of thing I don't I
don't think you have to go One Direction
or the other there you're in a midlevel
you're in a mid middle decision where
you are where you're getting to do some
of the legal aid work and like you said
you're getting great mentorship you're
in court every day so for a season
staying where you are might not be bad
um then a third option pops into my head
because I'm entrepreneurial I wonder
what kind of Boutique Law Firm you could
uh own and operate after you've got a
little bit more experience under your
belt that would allow you to make a
couple hundred thousand and still have a
lot of room for pro bono and you select
the type of legal aid you want to
provide um as a part of the business
model of running your own firm at some
point uh where you made serious money
off of uh good people that you want to
help uh and you're also have have the
the margin to do the other stuff too so
there there's a lot of different ways to
get at this um uh I I I just I I don't I
always
um uh resist the idea that the only way
you can do something Noble and
fulfilling is to be broke right that's
quite the contrary is true you can do a
lot of noble and fulfilling things and
you know the people that you're helping
will uh help you to help others in the
process and um so I I you know I don't
mind where you are for a period of time
uh it's it's it's scratching a whole lot
of your itches right now yeah and just
say okay this is my uh this is my
internship this is my apprenticeship and
I'm going to do this for 3 years or I'm
going to do this for four years and then
I'm going to take that and go open a
boutique firm make serious money on part
of my clients and pro bono the rest of
them and still scratch a lot of that
itch I don't think you have to
necessarily build up a pile of wealth
and then work for nothing at legal aid
to have done good in society or done
good in society the way you're defining
it even I I I uh so I I just I you've
done and I love that you did this
debt-free that's pretty stinky you and I
were talking about this recently that
most young people don't realize the
amount of law schools that are in this
country because they think well I got to
go to the bigname law school you know
ivy league or a Vander built in our in
our neck of the woods but there are law
schools in every state that if you have
the right GPA and the elsat score they
will give you a full ride Lexi's an
example of this and I want to applaud
her too Dave because here's a young lady
who's come out and she's getting
courtroom experience which is incredibly
valuable she's right her colleagues are
sitting in the cube they're waiting for
their chance of getting Court she's in
there every day on the battlefield I
like I like uh uh my option plus Dave's
option Lexi I thought both of those are
sound ideas for you you can give back
but you can move up at the same time
they're not separate choices as Dave
said that's a false narrative and and
you don't need to feel bad I I didn't
like how she said and you know I have to
suck it up and go to the big Law Firm I
wouldn't look at it that way you know
and and I would look at it as if I don't
like the big Law Firm that's one thing
but moving up doesn't mean that I'm
somehow not being authentic to who I am
and wanting to use the law for good yeah
she just doesn't want to she didn't like
that environment I think part of and I
don't blame her for that I agree I get
blame her for that basically they ride
you like a horse man I mean it's like
nuts um so yeah I don't I don't I don't
argue that part of it um but you know
there's um there's a lot of ways to get
at helping F the helping folks um with
you know with the law and there a lot of
lot of angles on that that you can do
that are not in any way a sellout so
good question good question you're
amazing young lady thank you for calling
in this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
our scripture of the day Luke 14:28
suppose one of you wants to build a
tower won't you sit down first and
estimate the cost to see if you have
enough money to complete it Dan Miller
that we referenced at the top of the
hour uh said success is never an
accident it typically starts as
imagination becomes a dream
stimulates a goal grows into a plan of
action which then inevitably meets with
opportunity don't get stuck along the
way that's good great quot open phones
at
88255 225 Morgan is in Ann Arbor
Michigan hey Morgan how are you I'm
doing great how are you better than we
deserve what's
up yeah my husband and I have been
married for about two and a half years
and we have no debt um we would love to
buy a house invest more into retirement
and grow our wealth but with the budget
we have there seems to be no extra room
even though we're living on as minimum
as we can so what advice do you guys
have for growing wealth on a small
budget or maybe maximizing that
wealth well either you're not living on
as little as you can or you don't make
much money which is
it I I think if we don't make much money
um what's your household income about
$50,000 okay yeah you're below average
don't mean that in a negative way I'm
just saying the average is 72,000
nationally what do you each
do my husband is an audiovisual
technician and I currently don't work
I'm a full-time student we have a baby
full-time student when will you be
done um in about six months and what do
you plan to
do I don't really plan to work I
probably plan to stay home with the kids
and eventually homeschool my kids why
did you get a
degree um I'm not paying for it so it
it's kind of presented to me as a way to
I got I started school before I got
married and was maybe going to use it
then and now I am married for a few
years with kids so what's your degree in
Christian
Ministries okay all right um well I mean
there there's only two sides to the
equation the income and the
outgo and so if you all want to address
your income side then you're going to
have more
margin it's that simple you'll have more
you'll have more wiggle room in this
budget um if you you said you got two
kids one one kid one kid okay and you
guys are what
25 uh I'm 21 my husband's 26 okay all
right and um so I mean you do not have a
lot of room in a $50,000 budget um that
would make sense and nrb Michigan uh I
mean it's not like you're some kind of
crazy spender like you're going you know
out on the town buying $300 dinners
every night I know you're not you don't
have room in that budget to do that
you've done a good job staying within
that budget not getting into debt way to
go good job um but I think what you've
got to do is you have you know I I
remember a guy teaching one time I was
in a a a conference on leadership and
business and he said the problem with
hitting goals is not what you're willing
to do to get there it's what you're
willing to give up to get there and
giving up in your all's case might be uh
if we want to have a house we're going
to have to give up some time and be
working if we want want to build some
wealth we're going to have to trade some
time for that and so um at 21 with a
baby you've got this uh stay-at-home mom
homeschooling thing dream dialed in
which is's nothing wrong with at all my
wife stayed at home with our children uh
but you have to on the other side of the
equation then go make some stinking
money and uh if if you're going to be
doing that he's going to be working more
and or differently mhm what's a number
do you guys have an idea in your head
how much more per month would make a
real difference for you
realistically I mean probably $500 to
$1,000 because that's $500,000 put
straight savings okay here's why I asked
that question it's really important to
get that number in your head and you two
sit down and go okay what do we have to
do to come up with an additional
thousand could you find some of that in
the budget it's possible I don't think
you have a lot of fat so now it's how do
I make a th000 how does he make a th you
know can we do it collectively could you
make a th even being home with the one
baby could he make a th000 you can you
can rack that up pretty quickly and now
all of a sudden you've got $2,000 but
you've got to reverse engineer your
activity to go all right this is what
has to be true for us to be able to make
an additional $11,000 and if you go
above and beyond that that's fine but
that's when you get some laser focus and
now you've got that margin yeah I'm
going to send you a copy of Ken's book
from paycheck to purpose for your
husband
uh and you can read it too of course
yeah but um what I'm thinking about for
him is I think this is just a job he
fell into like he ran sound over at the
church and some buddies that were in The
Sound business said come work for us now
he runs sound and um I you know he's 26
so you start asking yourself the
question what am I doing when I'm
36 that I'm making 100,000 instead of 50
that's right and do I own the sound
company me do I have a completely
different career Direction uh do I take
a class or two to make myself more
valuable uh but if you keep doing the
same thing over and over again expecting
a different result that's the definition
of insanity so change something and um
find and from paycheck to purpose helps
lead him through a really clear path to
do that yeah it'll go from ideation in
stage one all the way to realization of
that as Dave is talking about 10 year 20
year 30y year plan and he's got some
skill set he's got some experience he
can freelance with that skill set but he
needs to be raising the bar as to what
he can make in the now but with an eye
on the next and that's that's how you
guys get to real Financial uh
Independence and then the ability to do
whatever you want to fund those dreams
very good excellent stuff all right Nick
is with us in sou Fall South Dakota hi
Nick what's
up hey thanks for taking my call
gentlemen how are you guys doing better
than we deserve how can we help sir
excellent so so here's my question my
wife and I are new to the Ramsey program
um we you know we have uh significant
savings um already built up we do have
some Consumer Debt that I think we can
manage rather quickly what is the how
much significant
savings about 18,000 and that's not in
retirement no no no and how much how
much how much debt do you have
so I have uh uh couple car loans in a in
a credit card so1 18,000 for my wife's
car seven on my daughter's car and a
credit card um that uh that we have on
the remainder yeah um okay so how can we
help well so my question is um you know
my wife and I are once we uh take care
of this Consumer Debt in in we start to
tackle our
mortgage we sort of have a disagreement
I'm I contribute roughly 35% of my
income to retirement and the question is
should I reduce that and take that extra
money and contribute it towards our
mortgage in addition
to any additional funds that gotcha well
Nick what we teach is this idea of Total
Focus because your most powerful wealth
building tool is your income if you
didn't have any payment right now except
your house you have a lot of wiggle room
in this
budget and so you've been trying to do
three things at once and you ended up
financing your car because you're
overinvestigation i' reduce it to zero
temporarily temporarily I'd not go out
to eat not go on vacation I'd be on a
tight budget scorched Earth you and your
wife sit down make every penny scream
and then I would take every dollar of
that 18 except $1,000 and I would throw
it at your smallest debts list your
debts smallest to largest and pay them
off in that order so those cards and
that daughter's car are gone the debts
gone we're going to put a big chunk on
your wife's and then we're going to
attack your wife's really really quickly
and get it finished up now you got no
payments but a house payment that feels
good
although it didn't feel good to stop
that 401k for a minute but it was just
for a hot minute now we're going to
build an emergency fund back of 3 to 6
months of expenses put that savings back
and then you got your rainy day fund and
then you restart your
401k the problem is you try to do
everything it want so you're doing
nothing and that's the order of attack
hang on I'll send you a copy of the book
The Total Money Makeover to help you do
it Ken Coleman good show today thank you
sir that puts this hour of the Ramsey
Show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
[Music]
Jesus
n